homage
[Applause]
their stories also reveal a lot about
the state of our world and
the state of our union they show the
power of humanity
and the sense of mourning which will
live long in our society
and they expose to us
the fragility all around us
a virus a thousand times smaller than a
grain of sand
exposed how delicate life can be
it laid bare the strains on our health
systems
and the limits of a model that values
wealth
above well-being
it brought into sharper focus the
planetary fragility
that we see every day through melting
glaciers
burning forests and now through global
pandemics
it changed the way we behave and
communicate
keeping our arms at length and our faces
behind
masks it showed us
just how fragile our community of values
really is and how quickly it can be
called into questions
around the world and even here in our
union
but people want to move out of this
corona world
out of this fragility out of this
uncertainty
they are ready for change and they are
ready to move on
and this is the moment for europe
the moment for europe to lead the way
from this fragility towards a new
vitality and that is what i want to talk
about
today honorable members
i say this because in the last month
we have rediscovered the value of what
we hold in common
as individuals we have all sacrificed
a piece of our personal liberty for the
safety of others
and as a union we all shared
a part of our sovereignty for the common
good
we turned fear and division between
member states
into confidence in our union we show
that it is possible and what is possible
when we trust each other and we trust
the european institutions
and with all of that we choose to
not only repair and recover for the here
and now
but to shape a better world a better way
of living
for the world of tomorrow and this is
next generation eu this is
our opportunity to make change
happen by design and not by disaster
or by dictate from others in the world
to emerge
stronger by creating opportunities for
the world of tomorrow
and not just building contingency
contingencies
for the world of yesterday we have
everything we need to make this happen
we have shaken off the old excuses and
home comforts
we have the vision we have a plan
we have the investment it is now time to
get to work
this morning i've sent a letter of
intent
to president sasali and chancellor
merkel on behalf of the german
presidency
outlining the commission's plan for the
year ahead
i will not present every initiative
today
but i want to touch on what our union
must focus on
in the next 12 months
honorable members the people of europe
are still
suffering it is a period of profound
anxiety for millions
who are concerned about the health of
their families
the future of their jobs or simply
getting through till the end of the
month
the pandemic and the uncertainty that
goes with it
is not over and the recovery is still in
its early stage
so our first priority is to pull each
other through this
and to be there for those that need it
and thanks to our unique social market
economy
europe can do just that
it is above all a human economy
that protects us against the great risks
of
life illness
ill fortune unemployment
and poverty it offers stability
and helps us better absorb shocks
it creates opportunities and prosperity
by promoting
innovation growth and fair competition
never before has that enduring
promise of protection stability
and opportunity being more important
than it is today
allow me to explain why
first europe must continue to protect
lives and livelihoods
this is all the more important in the
middle of a pandemic that shows
no sign of running out of steam or
intensity
we know how quickly numbers can spiral
out of control
so we must continue to handle this
pandemic pandemic
with extreme care responsibility and
unity
in the last six months our health
systems
and workers have produced miracles
every country has worked to do its best
for its citizens
and europe has done more together
than ever before when the member states
closed borders
we created green lanes for goods when
more than 600 000 european citizens
were stranded all over the world the eu
brought them
back home when some countries introduced
export bans for critical medical goods
we stopped that and ensured that
critical medical goods
should go where it was needed we worked
with the european industry to increase
the production of masks of gloves
of tests of ventilators our civil
protection mechanism ensured
that doctors from romania could treat
patients in italy
or that latvia could send masks to his
baltic neighbors
and we achieved all that without
having full competencies so for me it is
crystal clear
we need to build a stronger european
health union it is time to do that
and to start making this a reality we
must now draw the first lessons from the
health crisis
we need to make our new e4 eu for health
program
future proof and this is why i had
proposed to increase
funding and i'm grateful that this
parliament
is ready to fight for more funding
and remedy the cuts made by the european
council
and we need to strengthen our crisis
preparedness and management
of cross-border health issues
as a first step we will propose to
reinforce
and empower the european medicine
agency and ecdc our center for disease
prevention and control
as a second step we
will build a european barda
an agency for biomedical advanced
resource
research and development this new agency
will support our capacity and readiness
to respond to cross-border threats and
emergencies
whether of natural or deliberate origin
we need strategic stockpiling
to address supply chain dependencies
notably for pharmaceutical goods
and as a third step it is clearer than
ever that we must discuss
the question of health competencies
and i think it is a noble and urgent
task
to do this for the conference on the
future
of europe
and finally and because it was a global
crisis
we need to learn the global lessons
this is why along with prime minister
conte
and the italian g20 presidency next year
i will convene a global health summit
next year in italy this will show
europeans that our union is there
to protect them all
and this is exactly what we have done
when it comes to workers
when i took office i vote to create an
instrument
to protect workers and businesses
from external shocks because i knew from
my experience as a minister for labor
and social affairs
that these schemes work they keep people
in jobs
they keep the skills in the companies
and of course they keep the business the
smes in business
these smes are the motor of our economy
and they will be the engine of our
recovery
and this is why the commission created
the shure program
and i want to thank this house
for working on it in record time
if europe has so far avoided mars
unemployment
seen elsewhere it is thanks in large
part
to the fact that around 40
million people applied for short time
work schemes
the speed and the unity of purpose means
that 16 countries will soon receive
almost
90 billion euros from sure
to support workers and companies from
lithuania
to spain it will give peace of mind
to families who need that income to
put food on the table or to pay the rent
and it will help protect millions of
jobs incomes and companies
right across our union this is
real european solidarity
in action and it reflects the fact
that in our union the dignity of work
must
be sacred
but the truth is that for too many
people
work no longer pays
dumping wages destroys the dignity of
work
penalizes the entrepreneur who pays
decent wages
and distorts fair competition in the
single market and this has to stop
and this is why the commission will put
forward a legal proposal
to support member states to set up a
framework for minimum wages everyone
must have access
everyone must have access to minimum
wages
either through collective bargaining
or through statutory minimum wages
i personally i am a strong advocate of
collective bargaining
and the proposal will fully respect
national competences and traditions
we have seen in many web member states
that introduced
collectively bargained minimum wages
how a well-negotiated minimum wage
secures jobs and creates
fairness both for the workers and for
the companies who
really value them so honorable members
minimum wages work and it is time
that work paid
the second promise of the social market
economy is that of
stability
by showing it was united and up to the
task
europe provided the stability that our
economies need
and we'll not forget when the crisis hit
the commission immediately triggered the
general escape clause for the very first
time in our history
we flexibilized our european funds and
state aid rules
authorizing more than 3 trillion euro
in support to companies and industry
from fishermen in croatia to farmers in
greece
from smes in italy to freelancers in
denmark
the european central bank took decisive
action through the pep
program the commission proposed next
generation eu
in record time thus combining
investment in the much much needed
reforms
the council endorsed it in record time
this house is working towards
voting on it with maximum speed
honorable members for the first time
and for exceptional times europe has
put in place its own common tools
to complement national fiscal
stabilizers
this is a remarkable moment of unity in
the european union
and this is an achievement we should
take collective
pride in we made that
and now it's time to hold our course
we have all seen the forecasts
we can expect our economies to start
moving again
after a 12 drop in gdp in the second
quarter
but as the virus lingers
so does the uncertainty here in europe
and around the world
so this is definitely not the time
to withdraw support our economies need
continued policy support and the
delicate balance will need to be struck
between providing financial support
and ensuring fiscal sustainability
in the longer term there is no greater
way
to stability and competitiveness
than through a stronger economic and
monetary union
confidence in the euro has never been
stronger
the historic agreement on next
generation eu
shows the political backing that it has
and we must now use this opportunity to
make structural reforms in our economies
and complete the capital markets union
and the banking union deep and liquid
capital
markets are essential to give businesses
access to the finance they need and they
needed to grow and invest in recovery
and in the future
and they are also a prerequisite to
further strengthen
the international role of the euro so
let's get to work
and finally complete this generational
project
and the third enduring promise is
the promise of opportunity
the pandemic reminded us of many things
we have
may have forgotten or we may have taken
for granted
we were reminded how linked our
economies are
and how crucial a fully functioning
single market
is to our prosperity and to the way we
do things
the single market is all about
opportunity
opportunity for consumers to get value
for money
opportunities for a company to sell
everywhere in europe
and opportunities for the industry to go
to drive
global competitiveness and for all of us
it is about the opportunity
to make the most of the freedoms we
cherish
as europeans it gives our companies the
scale they need to prosper
and the safe heaven for them in times of
troubles
we rely on it every day to make our
lives easier
and it is crucial for managing the
crisis
and recovering our strength so let's
give it a boost
we must tear down the barriers of the
single market
we must cut red tape we must step up
implementation and enforcement and we
must restore the four
freedoms in full and as fast as possible
the linchpin of this is a fully
functioning schengen area of free
movement
and we will work with parliament and
member states
to bring this high up on our political
agenda
and we will propose a new strategy for
the future of schengen
based on this strong internal market
the european industry has long powered
our economy
providing a stable living for millions
and creating the social hubs around
which our communities
are built we presented
a new industry strategy in march
to ensure industry could lead the trin
green and digital transition
last six months have only accelerated
that transformation
at a time when the global competitive
landscape is
fundamentally changing as to
we have to keep up and this is why
we will update our industry strategy
in the first half of next year and
adapt our com competition framework
which should also keep pace
honorable members all this
will ensure europe gets back on its feet
but as we pull through together we must
also propel ourselves forward
in the world of tomorrow and there is no
urgent need for acceleration
no more urgent need for acceleration
than when it comes
to the future of our fragile planet
while much of the world's activity froze
during lockdowns and shutdowns
the planet continued to get dangerously
hotter
and we see it all around us
from houses evacuated due to the glacier
collapse on the moblon
to fires burning through oregon to crops
destroyed in romania by the most severe
droughts
in decades but we also saw
nature coming back into our lives
we longed for green spaces and clean air
for mental health and our physical
well-being
we know change is needed and we also
know it is possible the european green
deal is
our blueprint to make that
transformation
at the heart of it is our mission
to become the first climate neutral
continent
in 2050 but we will not get there with
the status quo
we need to go faster and we need
to do things better we
looked in depth in every sector
to see how fast we could go
and how to do it in a responsible
evidence-based way we held a wide public
consultation
and conducted an extensive impact
assessment
and on this basis the european
commission
is proposing to increase the 2030
targets for emission reduction
to at least 55 percent
i recognize that this increase from 40
to 55
is too much for some and not enough for
others
but our impact assessment clearly shows
that our economy and
industry can manage this and they want
it
just yesterday 170 business leaders and
investors
from smes to some of the world's biggest
companies
wrote to me calling on europe to set a
target
at least at 55 percent our impact
assessment clearly shows that meeting
this target
would put the european union firmly on
track
for climate neutrality by 2050 and
for meeting our paris agreement
obligations
and if others follow our lead
the world will be able to keep warming
below 1.5
degrees celsius i'm fully aware that
many of our partners are far away from
that
but we have to lead and i will come back
to the carbon board adjustment mechanism
later
but for us the 2030 target
is ambitious it's achievable and it is
beneficial for europe
we can do it and we have already shown
that we can do it
while emissions dropped 25 since 1990
our economy grew more than 60 percent
the difference is now that we now have
the technology
we have way more expert expertise and we
have the investment
and we're already embarking towards a
circular economy
with carbon neutral production we want
to be leading in the world on that
we have more young people pushing for
change
we have more proof that what is good for
the climate
is good for business and is good for us
all
and we have a solemn promise to leave no
one behind in this transformation
without just transition fund we will
support the regions that have a bigger
and more costly change to make we
have it all now it's our responsibility
to implement it and to make it happen
and i want you at my side and i invite
you for this endeavor
because we only can do it together this
is
our mission on the european level
honorable members
meeting this new target
we'll reduce our energy import
dependency
we'll create millions of extra jobs
and more than half air pollution
pollution
to get there we have to start now
by next summer we will revise all of our
climate and energy legislation
to make it fit for 55
we will enhance emission trading boost
renewable energy
improve energy efficiency
reform energy taxation
but the mission of the european green
deal
involves much more than cutting
emissions
this is important but it is about making
systemic modernization across our
economy
society and industry it is about
building a stronger world to live in
our current levels of consumption of raw
material
energy water food and land use is
not sustainable we need to change how we
treat nature
how we produce and consume how we live
and work
eat and heat travel and transport
so we will tackle everything from
hazardous chemicals to deforestation
to pollution this is a plan for a true
recovery
it is an investment plan for europe and
this is where next generation eu will
make
a real difference firstly
37 of next generation eu
will be spent directly on our european
green deal objectives
and it i will ensure that it also takes
green financing to the next level
we are world leaders in green finance
and we are the largest issuer of green
bonds worldwide
we are leading the way in developing a
reliable
eu green bond standard and i can
announce today
that we will set a target of 30
of next generation eu's 750 billion
euros
to be raised through green bonds
secondly next generation
you should invest in lighthouse european
projects with the biggest
impact hydrogen renovation
and one million electric charging points
and allow me to explain how this could
work
two weeks ago in sweden a unique
fossil-free
steel pilot began test operations
it will replace coal with hydrogen
to produce clean steel this shows the
potential of hydrogen
to support our industry with the new
with a clean license to operate
i want next generation eu to create new
european hydrogen valleys
to modernize our industries to power
our vehicles and to bring new life to
our rural areas
the second example other buildings we
live and work
in our buildings generate
more than 40 of our emissions
they need to become less wasteful
less expensive and more sustainable
and we know that the construction sector
can even be turned
from a carbon source into a carbon
sink if organic building materials like
wood
and smart technologies like ai are being
used
so i want next generation eu to kick
start
a european renovation wave and make our
union a leader
in the circular economy but this is not
just an environmental or economic
project
it needs to be a new cultural project
for europe
every movement has its own look and feel
and we need to give our systemic change
its own distinct aesthetics
to match style with sustainability
and this is why we will set up
a new european bauhaus
a co-creation space where architects
artists students engineers designers
work together to make that happen
this is next generation eu this is
shaping the world we want to live in
a world served by an economy that cuts
emission
boosts competitiveness reduces energy
poverty
creates rewarding jobs and improves
quality of life
a world where we use digital
technologies to build
build a healthier a greener society
and this can only be achieved if we
all do it together and i will insist
that recovery plans don't just bring us
out of the crisis
but also help us propel europe
forward in the world of tomorrow
see you guys
transformation
has begun
2015
you
hand
to consumer
[Music]
retirement
for online learning home office online
shopping
and field philadelphia
is
in the next generation from
supercomputer and unconditional
that is bits and technology made in
europe
site altar by the end of underground
and ambition
honorable members europe is determined
to use this transition
to build the world we want to live in
and that of course
extends well beyond our external borders
the pandemic has simultaneously shown
both the fragility of the global system
and the importance of cooperation to
tackle collective change
and in the face of the crisis some
around the world
choose to retreat into isolation
others actively destabilize the system
europe choose to reach out
our leadership is not about self-serving
propaganda
it is not about europe first
it is about being the first to seriously
answer the call when it is needed
in the pandemic european planes
delivering
thousands of tons of protective
equipment
landed everywhere from sudan to
afghanistan
somalia to venezuela we know
no of us will ever be safe until all of
us are safe and we know wherever
we live whatever we have there has to be
access
affordable and safe access to vaccines
treatments and diagnostics
at the beginning of the pandemic there
was no funding
there was no global framework for a
covet
19 vaccine there was just the rush
to be the first one to get one and this
was the moment when the european union
stepped up to lead the global response
with civil society with g20
with who and others we brought
more than 40 countries together
to raise 16 billion euros
to finance research on vaccines on tests
on treatments for the whole world and
this
is europe's unmatched convening
power we can be so proud of
it is not enough to find a vaccine
we need to make sure that european
citizens and those around the world
have access to it and just this month
the european union joined the kovacs
global facility
and contributed 400 million euro
to help ensure that safe vaccines
are available not only for those who can
afford it
but for everyone who needs it because we
know
vaccine nationalism puts lives
at risks only vaccine cooperation
saves lives
[Applause]
honorable members we are firm believers
in the strength and value of cooperating
in international bodies
it is with a strong united nation that
we can find long-term solutions
for crisis like libya and syria it is
with a strong world health organization
that we can better prepare and respond
to global pandemics or local outbreaks
be it corona or ebola and it is with a
strong world
trade organization that we can ensure
fair competition for all
but the truth is also that the need
to revitalize and to reform the
multilateral system
has never been so urgent our global
system has grown into a creeping
paralysis
major powers are either pulling out
or they're taking the institutions
hostage for their own interests
and neither road will lead
anywhere yes we need change
but we need change by design and not
by destruction of our international
system
and this is why i want the european
union to lead reforms on w-h-o
and w-t-o so that they are fit for
today's
world but we know that multilateral
reforms take time
and in the meantime the world will not
stop
without any doubt there's a clear need
for europe to take clear positions
and quick actions on global affairs
two days ago the latest eu china leaders
meeting took place
the relationship between the european
union and china
is simultaneously one of the most
strategically important and
one of the most challenging we have and
from the outset we have said
china is a negotiating partner
an economic competitor and
a systemic rival
we have interest and common on issues
such as climate
change and china has shown it is
willing to engage through a high level
dialogue but we expect
also china to live up to his commitments
in the paris agreement
and to lead by example
in the economic field there's still hard
work to do
on a fair market access for european
companies
reciprocity and over capacity
and we continue to have an unbalanced
trade and investment partnership
and there is no doubt that we promote
very different systems of governance and
society
we believe in the universal value
of democracy and the rights of the
individual
europe is certainly not without issues
think for example of growing
anti-semitism
but criticism and opposition we discuss
them here
publicly criticism and opposition are
not
only accepted but they are legally
protected
there is an open debate about all these
issues
so we must call out human rights abuses
whenever and wherever they occur
be it on hong kong or be it with the ui
course
but what holds us back
why are even even simple statements on
eu values
delayed watered down or held hostage for
other motives
when member states say europe is
too slow i say
be courageous and finally move to
qualified majority voting
at least on human rights and sanctions
[Applause]
implementation
[Applause]
this house has called many times for
european magnitsky act
and i can announce that we will now come
forward with a proposal
we need to complete our toolbox
honourable members be it in hong kong
moscow or minsk
europe must take a clear and swift
position
and i want to say it loud and clear the
european union is
on the side of the people of belarus
[Applause]
we have all been moved by the immense
courage
of those peacefully gathering in the
independent square
or taking part in the field as women's
march
the elections that brought them into the
streets were neither free
nor fair and the brutal response by the
government
ever since has been shameful
the people of belarus must be
free to decide their own future
for themselves they are not pieces on
someone else's
chessboard
and to those that advocate closer ties
with russia
i say that the poisoning of alexei
navalny
with an advanced chemical agent is not
a one off we have seen the pattern in
georgia
and in ukraine in syria and salisbury
and an election meddling around the
world
and this pattern is not changing
and no pipeline will change that
turkey is and will always be an
important neighbor
but while we are close together on the
map
the distance between us appears to be
growing
yes turkey is in a troubled neighborhood
and yes it is hosting millions of
refugees
for which we support them with
considerable funding
but none of this is justification for
attempts
to intimidate their neighbors
our member states cyprus and greece can
always count on europe's
full solidarity on protecting their
legitimate
sovereignty rights
the escalation in the eastern
mediterranean is in our mutual interest
the return of exploratory vessels to
turkish posts
in the past few days is a positive step
in this direction
this is necessary to create the much
needed space for dialogue
refraining from unilateral actions
and resuming talks in good faith
is the only path forward
the only path to stability and lasting
solutions
honourable members
as well as responding more assertively
to global events
europe must deepen and refine its
partnerships
with its friends and allies
and this starts with revitalizing
our most enduring partnerships
we might not always agree with recent
decisions of the white house
but we will always cherish the
transatlantic alliance
based on shared values and history and
an
unbreakable bond between our people
so whatever what may happen later this
year
we are ready to build a new
transatlantic agenda
to strengthen our bilateral partnership
be it on trade on tech or taxation
and we are ready to work together on
reforming the international system we
build together jointly with like-minded
partners
for our own interests and in the
interest of the common good
we need new beginnings with old
friends on both sides
of the atlantic and on both sides
of the channel the scenes in this very
room
when we held hands and saying goodbye
with
old lang syne spoke a thousand words
and they showed an affection for the
british people that will never fade
but with every day that passes the
chances for
timely agreement do start to fade
negotiations are always difficult and we
are used to that
and the commission has the best and most
experienced negotiator michelle barney
to navigate us through that but talks
have not
progressed as the we would have wished
and that leaves us
very little time as ever as ever
this house will be the first to know and
it will be
the one that has the last say and i can
assure you we will continue to update
you
thoroughly just as we did with the
withdrawal agreement this withdrawal
agreement
took three years to negotiate
and we worked relentlessly on it line by
line
word by word and together we succeeded
and the result guarantees our citizens
rights
financial interests the integrity of the
single market
and crucially the good friday agreement
and the european union and the uk
jointly agreed
it was the best and only way for
ensuring
peace on the island of ireland and we
will never backtrack on that
and this agreement has been ratified by
this house
and by the house of commons it cannot
be unilaterally changed disregarded or
disapplied
this is a matter of law and trust and
good faith
[Applause]
and that is not just me saying it
i remind you of the words of margaret
thatcher i quote
britain does not break treaties it would
be bad for britain
bad for relations with the rest of the
world and bad for any future treaty on
trade
end of quote this was true then and this
is true today
trust is the foundation of any strong
partnership
and europe will always be ready to build
strong partnerships
with our closest neighbors this starts
with the western balkans
the decision six months ago to open
accession negotiations
with albania and north macedonia was
truly
historical indeed
the future of the whole region lies in
the european union
we share the same history we share the
same destiny
the western balkans are part of europe
and they're not
just a stop over on the silk road
we will soon present an economic
recovery package for the western balkans
focusing on a number of regional
investment initiatives
and we will be there for the eastern
partnership countries
and our partners in the southern
neighborhood to help create jobs
and kick-start their economies
when i came into office i chose for the
very first trip outside
the european union to visit the african
union
and it was a natural choice it was a
natural choice and it was a very clear
message
because we are not just neighbors
but we are natural partners
three months later i returned with my
entire college
to set out the priorities for a new
strategy
with africa it is a partnership of
equals where both sides share
opportunities
and responsibilities africa will be a
key partner in building the world we
want to live in
whether it is on climate digital or
trade
honourable members we will continue to
believe in open and fair trade across
the world
not as an end in itself but as a way to
deliver prosperity at home and promote
values and standards more than 600 000
jobs in europe are tied for example to
the trade with japan
and our recent agreement with vietnam
alone helped secure historic
labor rights for millions of workers in
the country
we will use our diplomatic strength and
economic clout
to broker agreements that make a
difference
such as designating maritime protected
areas in the antarctica this would be
one of the biggest
acts of environmental protection in
history
we will form high ambition coalitions on
issues such as the digital ethics
of fighting deforestation
and we will develop partnerships with
all like-minded partners from
asian democracies to australia africa
the americas and anyone else who wants
to join
we will work on just globalization
we cannot take this for granted
we must insist on fairness and a level
playing field
and europe will always move forward
alone or with partners
to do that
i want to come back to the carbon board
adjustment mechanism
carbon must have its price
because nature cannot pay this price
anymore
and this carbon board adjustment
mechanism should motivate foreign
producers
and eu importers to reduce their carbon
emissions
while ensuring that we level the playing
field
in a wto compatible way
the same principle applies to digital
taxation
we will spare no effort to reach
agreement in the framework of oecd and
g20
but let there be no doubt should an
agreement fall
short of a fair tax system that provides
long-term sustainable revenues
europe will come forward with a proposal
early next year i want europe to be a
global advocate for that
honourable members if europe is to play
a vital role
in the world it must also create
new vitality inside
and to move forward we must now overcome
the differences
that held us back the historic agreement
on next generation eu shows that it can
be done
and the speed with which we took
decisions on fiscal rule state aid or
sure
all this shows it can be
done so let's do it
migration is an issue that has been
discussed
long enough migration has
always been effect for europe and it
will
always be throughout centuries
it has defined our societies
it has enriched our cultures and it has
shaped many of our lives and this will
always be the case
as we all know the 2015 migration crisis
caused many deep divisions between
member states
with some of those scars still healing
today
a lot has been done since but a lot
is still missing if we are all ready to
make
compromises without compromising on our
principles
we can find a solution
next week the commission will put
forward its pact on migration
we will take a human and humane approach
and there are principles
saving lives at sea
is not optional
[Applause]
and those countries who fulfill their
legal and moral duties
or are more exposed than others
must be able to rely on the solidarity
of our
whole european union we will ensure a
closer link between asylum and return
we have to make a clear distinction
between those who have the right to stay
and those who do not we will take action
to fight smugglers
strengthen external borders deepen
external partnerships
and create legal pathways
and we will make sure that people who
have the right to stay
are integrated and made to feel
welcome they have a future to build
and skills energy and talent
i think of sweat
the teenage syrian refugee who arrived
in europe dreaming of being a medical
doctor
within three years she was awarded a
prestigious scholarship
from the royal college of surgeons in
ireland
i think of the libyan and somalian
refugee doctors
who offered their medical skills the
moment the pandemic
stuck in france and last year i told you
of the story of muas
whom i had the honor to meet
he is studying physics today
in europe honorable members
if we think about what they have
overcome
and what they have achieved then we
simply must be able to manage the
question of migration together
the images of the morya camp are a
painful reminder
of the need for europe to come together
everybody has to take a step up here and
take responsibility and the commission
will just do that
the commission is now working on a plan
for joint pilot with the greek
authorities
for new camp on lesbos we can assist
with asylum and return
processes and significantly improve the
conditions for the refugees
but i want to be clear
if we step up then i
expect all member states to step
up too migration is a european challenge
and a whole of europe must do its part
[Applause]
we must rebuild the trust among us and
move forward together
and this trust is at the very heart of
our union and the way we do things
together
it is anchored in our founding values
our democracies
and then our community of law as walter
heilstein
used to say this is not an abstract term
the rule of law helps protect people
from the rule of the powerful
it is the guarantor of our most basics
of everyday rights and freedoms
it allows us to give our opinion and to
be informed
by a free press before the end of the
month
the commission will adopt the first
annual rule of law report
covering all member states it is a
preventive tool
for early detection of challenges
and for finding solutions
i want this to be a starting point for
commissioned
parliament and member states to ensure
there is no
backsliding the commission attaches the
highest
importance to the rule of law
and this is why we will ensure that
money from our budget
a next generation eu is protected
against
any kind of fraud corruption or conflict
of interest
this is non-negotiable
but the last month have also reminded us
how fragile it can be
we have a duty to always be vigilant to
care and nurture
for the rule of law and breaches of the
rule of law
cannot be tolerated i will continue to
defend it and the integrity
of our european institutions
be it about the primacy of european law
the freedom of the press the
independence of the judiciary
all the sale of golden passports
european values are not
for sale
donna remembers these values are more
important than ever
i say that because when i think of the
state of the union
i am reminded of the words of john hume
one of the great europeans who sadly
passed away this year
if so many people live in peace today
on the island of ireland it is in large
part because of
his unwavering belief in humanity and
conflict resolution
he used to say that
conflict was about difference
and that peace was about respect
for difference and as he so rightly
reminded this house in 1998 and i quote
the european visionaries decided
that difference is not a threat
difference is natural difference
is the essence of humanity end of quote
and these words are just as important
today as they
ever have been because when i look
around
we ask ourselves where
is the essence of humanity when three
children in wisconsin watch their father
shot by the police while they sit in the
car
where is the essence of humanity
when anti-semite carnival costumes
openly parade on our streets
where is the essence of humanity
when every single day roma
people are excluded from society
and others held back simply because of
the color of their skin
or their religious belief
i am proud to live in europe in this
open society
of values and diversity but even here in
this union
these stories are daily reality for so
many people
and this reminds us that progress on
fighting racism and
hate is fragile it is hard
won but very easily lost
so now is the moment to make change to
build a truly anti-racist
union that goes from condemnation
to action and the commission is putting
forward an action play
plan to start making that happen
as part of this we will propose
to extend the list of eu crimes
to all forms of hate crime
and hate speech whether because of race
religion gender or sexuality
hate is hate and no one should have to
put up with that
[Applause]
we will strengthen our racial inequality
laws where there are gaps
we will use our budget to address
discrimination in areas such as
employment
housing or health care we will get
tougher on enforcement when
implementation lags behind
because in this human union fighting
racism
will never be optional
we will improve education and knowledge
on the historical
cultural causes of racism we will tackle
unconscious bias that exists in people
in institutions well yes and even in
algorithms
and we will appoint the commission's
first ever anti-racism coordinator
to keep this at the top of our agenda
and to work directly with people
civil society and institutions
honorable members i will not rest when
it comes to building
a union of equality
a union where you can be
who you are and love who you
want without fear
and recrimination
because being yourself is
not your ideology
it is your identity and
no one can ever take it away so i want
to be crystal clear
lgbtqi free zones
are humanity-free zones and they have
no place in our union
[Applause]
and to make sure that we support the
whole community
the commission will soon put forward a
strategy to strengthen lgbtqi rights
as part of this i will also push for
mutual
recognition of family relations in the
eu
because if you are a parent in one
country you are of course a parent
in every country
phone
[Music]
he
long live europe long live europa
um